It is a scientifically proven
fact that it is more fun to do
things with other people
than to do them alone.
This is why the bus was
invented in 1884.
This is also why the pizza
was invented by
the Italians in 1823.
It is even more scientifically
proven that watching stuff
with other people is more fun
than watching it yourself.
This is why the sofa was
invented in 1972.
By the way, the word sofa comes
from the words "so far,"
as in Google I/O is happening
so far from here that I'm
probably going to organize
an event and
watch it with my friends.
Anyways, there's this Google
I/O Extended thing that was
invented in 2009.
The main idea is to have an
event at the same time when
Google I/O happens in California
so that you have
all the news in real time.
You can discuss the news
as they are coming to
you through the tubes.
You can hack on the new APIs.
You can fantasize about once
having one of these [BLEEP]
that we're going to announce in
I/O. Basically, you bring
people in and have fun.
So if you're interested, we
have a couple of tips for
organizing Google
I/O Extendeds.
And we'd definitely like to
help make your Google I/O
Extended great.